[Music]
alex is a major tech enthusiast
recently he attended a virtual apple
launch event where he witnessed the
capabilities of the all-new iphone 13
series
instantly he made the decision to get an
iphone 13 pro however he missed the
pre-booking deadline and he's been
waiting for this phone to hit the
e-commerce sites ever since
after waiting for a long time he visited
the offline apple store where the store
representative informed him about an
ongoing delay in the production of
iphone 13 pro due to the supply chain
inefficiency
alex then went to a couple of more
trusted apple reseller outlets and
received the same response
he then became intrigued about this term
supply chain and how it affects the
production of a big corporation like
apple inc
therefore he began exploring this topic
he spoke with his friend rachel who
works at apple inc to learn about supply
chain management and how the chain is
disrupted due to international chip
shortage
rachel explained to him about supply
chain management using applelink's
example
she said if you order an iphone from the
apple store you'll notice that apple is
not precisely delivering the product on
its own
all the iphones available in apple store
are majorly manufactured at the shinsen
assembly plant in china
but before that raw material suppliers
from all around the world deliver goods
needed to manufacture an iphone to this
assembly site
and once the product is assembled it
gets shipped to the storage warehouse
and then to your doorstep by third-party
vendors like fedex or ups
this means entities such as raw
materials supplier manufacturer and
third-party logistics vendor are in
consistent communication with each other
until the iphone reaches you
these entities and their communication
involved in product manufacturing to
product delivery is collectively
considered as a supply chain after
listening to this alex asked rachel how
apple inc has implemented this supply
chain
and how can one design a sleek strategy
to manage a supply chain that is not
overly influenced by external factors
in response rachel explained well there
are five stages for building supply
chain management and apple has adopted
these stages while building the supply
chain management strategy
the first stage of building a supply
chain is planning an operational
strategy
apple since its inception has had a
clear goal
to provide the best personal computing
devices to consumers the initiative of
apple to scrutinize each app or program
before launching it on the apple app
store makes all apple devices more
secure these pre-planned actions or
strategies have been the most vital usps
of this organization
the next stage is sourcing
in this stage apple acquires equipment
and materials from suppliers and then
ships them to the offshore assembly
factory in china the 120 hertz screens
are exported from samsung's assan plant
foxconn ships batteries and the
processing chips are manufactured and
exported by tsmc
then comes the third stage known as
making
this is the stage where apple
manufactures its products the outsourced
chinese assembly plant majorly assembles
all apple products and ships them to the
warehouses or distribution centers
spread across multiple continents
after that the next stage of supply
chain management delivery comes into
play here the products ordered online
get shipped to the doorstep of consumers
from storage warehouses
whereas the distribution centers on the
other hand send items to retail stores
for offline sales this whole shipping
process is carried out by third-party
logistics vendors such as fedex
supply chain management's last building
stage is returns here the faulty or
damaged products during delivery get
shipped back to the storage warehouses
and then the assembly planned for
refurbishment
statistically speaking 97 of apple's
supply chain is all about outsourcing
agreements and collaborations
which has helped apple become the best
computing device producer
however due to the recent worldwide chip
shortage apple's supply chain has been
affected adversely the world was shut
down because of the covet 19 pandemic
and many factories also went down with
it leaving chip manufacturing materials
unavailable for months
increased consumer electronic demand in
recent times and scarcity of
semiconductor supplies
has put pressure on apple's supply chain
prompting the company to halt production
of 10 million iphone 13 devices
after listening to rachel alex learned
why there is a constant delay in the
delivery of iphones and became more
patient about his desire to buy an
iphone
on that note here's a question for you
from the given options which option does
not fall under the stages of supply
chain management
a
planning operational strategy
b
sourcing
c
making
d
disposal
do give it a thought and leave your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
with the help of an apple inc case study
we explored how a supply chain
management strategy can be established
this domain of business management is
crucial for any product or service based
company in the long run
a well-managed supply chain can lower
operational expenses allowing a firm to
gain more profit
it can also improve corporate brand
recognition and customer service
hence companies invest a great deal on
their supply chain they constantly hire
professional supply chain management
experts these professionals are tasked
with managing logistics updating the
company's inventory and conducting a
thorough evaluation of the manufacturing
cycle to discover and correct laws
that is the reason why these scm
professionals are compensated really
well
according to payscale the average salary
for supply chain managers is eighty-four
thousand dollars per annum whereas in
india the average annual salary is
around 8.5 lakhs per annum we hope you
enjoyed this video if you did a thumbs
up would be really appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simplylearn
[Music]
you